[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti cos'è una comunità
e qual è il senso di essere una comunità
la comunità è un concetto che non è
statico e un concetto variabile che è
variato nel tempo è un concetto che ci
porta alle rivoluzioni e quando è che
c'è una vera rivoluzione
una vera rivoluzione c'è quando c'è una
rivoluzione culturale
una rivoluzione che parte dal basso una
rivoluzione che parte dai cittadini
queste sono le vere rivoluzioni ma se
parliamo di comunità è impossibile non
parlare di beni comuni e la comunità che
gestisce si organizza per gestire i beni
comuni dei beni comuni partono dal
medioevo e la storia che ce lo dice e
sono cambiati negli anni e oggi sono
molto diversi e il campo di meno i
comuni il campo dell'istruzione della
cultura della tecnologia della
creatività ma se scendiamo il campo ai
beni comuni urbani
vediamo cosa sono i beni comuni
definiamoli il bene comune e quando
l'istituzione insieme ai cittadini
portano avanti un progetto di
cambiamento di rigenerazione e lo
portano con due ruoli ben diversi c'è il
ruolo del cittadino che un ruolo di
volontario il cittadino deve essere un
volontario e devi intervenire là dove il
comune non riesce o l'istituzione non
riesce a intervenire è l'istituzione
deve essere e deve avere un ruolo
professionale
c'è un dibattito globale incredibile in
questi ultimi anni sui cambiamenti delle
città e il dibattito ci porta gli stati
uniti d'america
cosa succede negli stati uniti d'america
i cittadini reclamano spazi abbandonati
spazi in disuso parchi pubblici orti
cittadini spazi alloggiativi chiusi in
disuso che però possono essere messi a
frutto per la using sociale per portare
dei beni
a chi è più è che almeno bianca
dall'altra parte c'è l'italia dove
pubblico e privato vanno insieme si
uniscono e prendono degli spazi pubblici
una volta pubblici che diventano beni
comuni
questo è il vero cambiamento ma c'è
tutto questo cambiamento anche una
critica una critica soprattutto dei
cittadini
no sentiamo sempre i cittadini che si
lamentano che il comune non pulisce i
parchi che il comune non tappa alle
buche ma questa critica e perché ci sono
meno finanziamenti
allora dove interveniamo noi come
cittadini intermedia mo con un valore
aggiunto abbiamo la possibilità di farlo
perché viviamo i nostri quartieri e chi
meglio di noi conosce il nostro
quartiere ci siamo vissuti siamo
cresciuti lo percorriamo ogni giorno
vediamo i cambiamenti
vediamo la decadenza ma vediamo anche
quando si riattiva il portiere è qui che
vi voglio portare tre esempi quattro
esempi il primo esempio milano
siamo in un periodo critico un periodo
di emergenza sanitaria e se
ripercorriamo quello che appena detto le
interazioni fra i cittadini le
interazioni sono diminuite nei quartieri
i cittadini hanno paura
cosa succede che i cambiamenti arrivano
in digitale nelle piattaforme tecnologia
quindi un cambiamento tecnologico il
colophon in civico cos'è il cro fanno in
civico il cav antin civico e quando il
comune un'istituzione mette a
disposizione dei finanziamenti per
rigenerare degli spazi pubblici profondi
civico la prima esperienza e quelle di
milano del 2015 oltre 330.000 persone
330 mila euro raccolti fondi raddoppiati
grazie al match funding
con il coinvolgimento di 1492
sostenitori di cui 154 erano
associazioni e cosa succede qui succede
e ce lo dice rodrigo davis illustre
ricercatore del massachusetts institute
of technology ci dice che quando
facciamo una campagna di crowd funding
per il bene comune
state sicuri che andrà a buon fine la 81
per cento delle campagne di crow funding
per finanziare cambiamenti cittadini e
generazione urbana è andata a buon fine
contro il 44 per cento che non andato a
buon fine perché non aveva un forum un
fine sociale
poi abbiamo bologna la città in cui ho
studiato che ha un ragionamento
regolamento così ti bologna collaborare
bologna
l'esperimento che fu fatto nel 2012 fu
fatto dal sindaco di allora su tre beni
comune una piazza un pezzo di portico e
un edificio pubblico
questo esperimento portò poi nel 2014 al
regolamento
questo regolamento oggi è seguito da più
di 60 paesi nel mondo di 60 città
rappresentante di 60 paesi nel mondo
cosa significa questo significa che più
di 200 soggetti 20 soggetti sono stati
proponenti firmando dei patti i patti
sono patti di collaborazione sono patti
in cui io dico come cittadino come
associazione di cittadini
cerco di intervenire per il beneficio
del del mio quartiere della mia della
cittadinanza e questo porta poi nel 2012
a un altro esperimento che quello della
social stretta cosa succede nella sua
stretta
succede che dei condomini cominciano un
con sharing rudimentale mettono a
disposizione una decina di biciclette
condominiali e cominciano a usare tra di
loro
tanti passi sono stati fatti avanti e
poi diventa si passa dal condominio alla
via cittadina
e quindi tutta la via viene coinvolta
con un sistema virtuale facebook dove ci
sono degli amministratori dove non si fa
politica dove non ci sono idee religiose
ma c'è solo il fine è il bene comune del
cittadino è lì che c'è il cambiamento
negli social street dove si capiscono le
skill delle persone e dove si mettono a
disposizione le proprie skill a
beneficio è a vantaggio della
cittadinanza e della propria via poi se
verona città in cui sono nato e sono
cresciuto che nel 2015 anche verona si
approccia a a un percorso di beni comuni
anche vero ma come lo fa lo fa con un
principio di sussidiarietà dove c'è un
patto con i cittadini dove i cittadini
intervengono questa è la definizione
degli stessi principi di sussidiarietà
intervengono laddove il comune non
riesce e ci sono 37 patti firmati con il
coinvolgimento di almeno venti
associazioni oggi in nove parti che sono
alla firma infine chiudiamo con new york
andiamo oltre oceano qui viene fatto da
un papà tura territoriale e cosa succede
che l'associazione 596 acri
un'associazione che ha mappato 150 piani
di rinnovamento urbano a new york ha
cercato di fare intervenire i cittadini
dicendo guardate che ci sono investitori
che stanno prendendo la vostra area ci
vogliono speculare sopra prendetevela
quest'area fateci attività rigenerate la
fateci biblioteche fatti parchi per i
bambini usate gli spazi abitativi perché
se non li prendono i cani investitori e
quello che è chiamata anche gente
ficazione cambiamento dei quartieri
l'agente applicazione è sempre a
vantaggio di pochi
ricordatevelo di più abbienti sono i
meno abbienti che perdono e quindi non è
più una rivoluzione sociale e quindi
voglio chiudere diciamo
dicendovi e lasciandovi un toolkit una
cassetta degli attrezzi con tre parole
chiave
cosa significa essere cittadini oggi
significa essere osservatore dovete
osservare che il meglio di voi conosce
il quartiere
cosa vorreste cambiare nel vostro
quartiere ve lo siete mai chiesto la
seconda parola chiave sognatori creativi
passare all'azione essere concreti
essere concreti significa anche
finanziare il progetto avere in mente
come poter finanziare quel progetto e
ultima parola chiave essere proattivi
mettere in campo un'idea e presentarla
presenta le accomuna tutti i comuni
hanno di formulare in cui voi potete
come cittadini attivi dire la vostra
prendete il coraggio perché il
cambiamento passa da voi e anche un
cittadino attivo può portare alla
rigenerazione del vostro quartiere
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]